this next story is almost beyond belief
the post facto smear campaign by the
right against right winger John Bolton
Donald Trump's former national security
adviser is growing in ways that might
even surprise a regular follower of
right-wing propaganda channels like Fox
News let me recap and then we'll get
into unbelievable video from Lou Dobbs
so to recap John Bolton recently said
Trump told me hold the aid to Ukraine
until they come out and smear Biden
publicly there is now a battle over
whether John Bolton should or will
testify in the Senate impeachment trial
of Donald Trump Friday there's going to
be a debate and a vote about that in the
Senate based on the schedule we know
right now will tell you ultimately
whether four or more Republicans do the
right thing and vote for John Bolton to
testify but in the meantime
right-wingers are smearing John Bolton
including pretending that John Bolton is
some kind of anti Trump bomb throwing
leftist which if you were around during
the era of the Iraq war you would know
that suggesting that John Bolton is any
kind of tool of the left is a comically
ridiculous claim check this out from the
Lou Dobbs show on phy I think he's on
fox business not Fox News proper where
Lou Dobbs devoted an entire segment to
smearing John Bolton as a tool of the
radical left this is not satire this is
not Saturday Night Live the architect of
the Iraq war one of the most evil war
mongering Republican reactionaries of
the last twenty years of American
foreign policy john bolton is now being
smeared as a tool of the left on fox
because he simply believes trump is
lying and trump is dangerous in this
clip you're going to see Lou Dobbs
present a whacked-out conspiracy theory
where Mitt Romney is also part of the
plot to take down Trump by pushing for
Bolton's testimony you've got to see it
to believe it
it actually takes some effort to even
follow this check it out Lou putting up
those conspiratorial spider charts where
everything is linked the likes of which
you often see on youtube channels
talking about George Soros conspiracy
theories take a look at this MIT Romney
have I said that name before
yes I have Mitt Romney's call for John
Bolton's testimony comes as no surprise
Romney has been let's say wobbly
throughout his long had connections with
foreign policy rhinos and they with him
Bolton one of them he served as Romney's
foreign policy advisor during Romney's
failed 2012 presidential run and current
national security adviser Robert O'Brien
also served as a foreign policy adviser
to Romney O'Brien also worked with
Bolton at the United Nations
when Bolton was the US ambassador both
Bolton and O'Brien led the National
Security Council that employed the likes
of the infamous anonymous whistleblower
never Trump ur lieutenant colonel alex
amendment and his brother yep yet even
Minh the Security Council senior ethics
lawyer okay so so far Lou Dobbs has
speculatively and circumstantially
linked and I used that term linked very
loosely MIT Romney to John Bolton and an
impeachment witness Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander VIN Minh who also has been
widely smeared by the right despite the
right claiming that they support and
trust members of the military a
lieutenant-colonel van Minh a longtime
member of the military they are smearing
him as well so let's continue and now
this is the key line the claim from Lou
Dobbs that John Bolton is a tool of the
left and something funny also happens in
this clip which also happens to Rudy
Giuliani when he is going on these
conspiracy rants Lou Dobbs sort of
starts to lose his train of thought and
at the end of the next clip he starts to
stumble and make no sense but the key
thing he refers to John Bolton
outrageous right-wing reactionary as a
tool for the radical left see how it
works you bet not so complicated is it
John Bolton himself has been reduced to
a tool for the radical dims in the deep
state with his well his allegation that
the president once told him that the the
the aid to the to the Ukraine was
entirely dependent on whether or not mr.
szalinski carried out investigations of
his political opponents consider the
revisionist history Republicans have
loved and trusted John Bolton for deck
Boulton was a key designer of the iraq
war and now bolton is simply saying i'm
not going to stand by trump I want to
tell what I believe to be the truth in
the impeachment trial the way he is
telling it in his book he is out the
right does not tolerate traitors but I
don't mean they don't tolerate traitors
to the US they gladly tolerate traitors
to the US the right doesn't tolerate
traitors to their party and their
movement and by the way mmm classic Lou
Dobbs moment Lou Dobbs years ago chiming
in on the Obama 10 suit controversy
remember this I think it was shocking a
lot of people is this an effort to make
him look warmer so that's Lou Dobbs for
you so understand this point right now
Donald Trump has such a group of
brown-nosing sycophants around him that
if Dick Cheney came out and said I'm
worried that what Donald Trump is doing
is bad for the country you would just as
quickly see Dick Cheney called the tool
for the radical left as well this is how
unhinged and disconnected from the facts
they are and they don't care and they'll
probably get away with it we'll have
more on this on our Instagram page at
David Pakman show on Instagram follow me
on Instagram while you're there at David
Pakman quick break after the break
Donald Trump has glitched yet again
including at at a recent New Jersey
rally we'll have video and we will
discuss it in just a few short minutes I
want to tell you about one of our
sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk and now breakfast has gotten
much more boring magic spoon is a new
cereal company that has discovered how
to recreate your favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar twelve grams of
protein and just three grams of net
carbs per serving they offer four
flavors based on the classics cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry plus the
variety pack which lets you try them all
magic spoon
more than a year working with the best
food scientists and chefs to recreate
the taste and texture of that classic
sugary cereal but it tastes so
incredible you would never guess that it
was healthy its keto friendly gluten
free grain free soy free low carb and
GMO free you've got to try it to believe
it because it tastes great my favorite
of course cocoa cocoa go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman grab a variety pack
and try it today make sure to use the
promo code Pakman at checkout to get
free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon dot-com / pakman promo code Pakman
4 shipping